back with a fox news alert u.s
government workers in tijuana are being
told to shelter in place as deadly
cartel violence rages in the city what
started as a prison riot there has
developed into a weekend of mass chaos
vehicles are being set on fire and at
least 11 feuding gang members have died
the terror spreading across the border
into california elsewhere on the border
texans have been fleeing this effect
of this out-of-control migrant crisis
their calls for accountability have
fallen on deaf ears but we are listening
watch
so the secretary of homeland security
says that the border is secure
is it absolutely not it's wide open and
it's been wide open since biden
took office the border's not closed at
all and we can see that throughout the
country it's not secure even
the border patrol who work under him say
it's not secure i was born and raised
here and growing up i've seen the border
come from different administrations and
under trump it was really safe i felt
really safe you know going about around
my city and now with biden i can't even
walk the street without seeing illegals
on the floor just sitting down i can't
like
drive my car without seeing illegal
immigrants being transported in buses so
i feel really unsafe now and i wish that
biden would do something about it as
time goes on the border just gets more
and more dangerous
girls my age and even younger are being
trafficked and raped and a large portion
of the people that cross over don't even
make it because the failure of this
administration to enforce repercussions
for illegal immigration only motivates
people to come and make that journey and
it's really like impacting the hispanic
demographic do you feel like the
president of the united states
cares about this issue
i would love to hope so but no i don't
think so joining me now national border
patrol council president brandon judd
brandon thank you so much for joining
the program now those are texans these
are people that have to live with this
this this problem every single day
and they're from all races all different
backgrounds yet their answers are the
same
yeah and texas is something that you
know very well about i mean it's near
and dear to your heart you know exactly
what's going on in texas and what we're
seeing is complete and total chaos and
it's unfortunate because it doesn't need
to be that way we could get this under
control uh overnight when you look at
what what president trump did with micro
protection protocols or better known as
remaining mexico it was like a light
switch he was dealing with difficult
problems with illegal immigration as
well because congress wasn't working
with him so he took it in his own hands
and he put in policies and programs that
allowed us to secure the border more
than we hadn't 45 years previous we had
a very secure border simply because we
had the right policies we had the right
programs when when president biden took
office he immediately got rid of those
policies and programs and that's why we
saw um a in an explosion in illegal
immigration and along with that comes
all of the other problems associated
with it the cartel violence the gangs um
that are coming into the united states
everything that's associated with
illegal immigration there should be no
surprise that the amount of drugs that
are on our street corresponds with
illegal immigration because the cartels
control what we're doing operationally
on our borders today you know it's
interesting because our our ice sources
in texas tell us that those asians are
fleeing in droves because they just
don't want to deal with it anymore and
i've heard the same thing from border
patrol as well but i want to get your
reaction on this tijuana
gang problems happen it's right across
the border as you know it was reported
earlier this year that there is a tunnel
from tijuana that leads all the way to
san diego what does this mean for the
american
national security
well it shows you how easily and how
quickly this can escalate into into
deadly violence when you see burned out
vehicles when you hear about the deaths
that are caused right there on our
border we know that it's also coming
into the united states i mean all you
have to do is look at what we've seen um
from from states that are very far away
from the border when you ask that
ten-year-old girl from ohio that was
raped by that illegal alien if you asked
her if our border was secure what do you
think she would say when you ask that
father in florida um that was murdered
by by the the foster child that claimed
to be 17 years old but was actually 24
that hhs placed with that with that
household i would say that they would
say that the border is not secure just
ask any law enforcement that is on the
border and they will tell you it's not
secure but again it simply goes back to
is there the political will to put in
place the policies and programs so that
we don't have the violence that we're
currently seeing in tijuana spill over
into the united states yeah
i have zero confidence in the
administration they know what to do they
refuse to do it
thank you so much brenda hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else